S
LIKELY THE VARIANT, THEY SAY,
WAS CIRCULATING WIDELY.
>> DAVID MCKENZIE, APPRECIATE
IT, THANKS FROM JOHANNESBURG.
JOINING US RIGHT NOW, SOMEONE
WHO CERTAINLY BOMBARDMENT
QUESTIONS, ITS DOCTOR ANTHONY
FAUCI, DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF ALLERGY AND
DISEASES.
AND PRESIDENT BIDEN'S CHIEF
MEDICAL ADVISER.
DOCTOR FAUCI, GOOD EVENING.
WE LEARNED TODAY THE FIRST
PERSON TO TEST POSITIVE FOR THE
MACRON VARIANT IN THE U.S. WAS
FULLY VACCINATED WITH THE
MODERNA VACCINE.
HADN'T RECEIVED A BOOSTER DOSE.
A LOT OF FOLKS OUT THERE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT THIS ALL
COULD MEAN.
SO WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE TONIGHT?
DO WE KNOW ENOUGH YET ABOUT
OMICRON, TO BE SPECIFIC, ABOUT
REALLY ANYTHING?
>> NO, ACTUALLY, ANDERSON, WE
DON'T.
HAVING A SINGLE PERSON WHO HAD
WHAT WOULD BE CONSIDERED A
BREAKTHROUGH INFECTION, BECAUSE
THE PERSON WAS FULLY
VACCINATED.
IT DOESN'T REALLY TELL YOU MUCH
AT ALL, BECAUSE WE HAVE
BREAKTHROUGH INFECTIONS WITH
DELTA, OR PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
FULLY VACCINATED.
VERY OFTEN, MORE OFTEN THAN NOT,
THEY HAVE MILD ILLNESS.
THEY DON'T GO ON TO ANY SERIOUS
CONSEQUENCE.
FROM WHAT WE'VE HEARD FROM OUR
COLLEAGUES AT UCSF IN SAN
FRANCISCO, IS THAT THIS PERSON
HAD MILD SYMPTOMS IN HIS
ACTUALLY IMPROVING.
BUT IT'S ONLY A SINGLE PERSON,
ANDERSON.
SO YOU REALLY CAN'T MAKE A
BROAD GENERAL STATEMENT OR
EXTRAPOLATION FOR WHAT WOULD GO
ON WITH UNVACCINATED PEOPLE, OR
PEOPLE WHO ARE BOOSTED.
SO THERE'S A LOT STILL TO BE
LEARNED, AND HOPEFULLY, OVER
THE ENSUING WEEKS, OR MAYBE 2
TO 3 WEEKS, WE WILL GET A LOT
MORE INFORMATION, MOSTLY FROM
OUR SOUTH AFRICAN COLLEAGUES,
WHO HAVE BEEN REALLY, REALLY
GOOD IN KEEPING US UP TO DATE
ON WHAT'S GOING ON, AND BEING
VERY TRANSPARENT.
--
>> YOU REALLY THINK 2 OR 3
WEEKS, WE WILL HAVE ENOUGH
INFORMATION FROM SOUTH AFRICA,
THAT CAN GIVE US A BETTER
SENSE.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S
GONNA HAPPEN IN THE NEXT COUPLE
OF WEEKS, ANDERSON, IS THAT
WE'RE GONNA GET THE VIRUS,
WHICH WE HAVE.
AND YOU GROW THE VIRUS, OR YOU
MAKE WHAT'S CALLED A PSEUDO
VIRUS.
WHICH IS A FORM OF VIRUS THAT
YOU COULD WORK WITH IN THE TEST
TUBE VERY EASILY.
THEN, WE'RE GONNA GET SERUM
FROM PEOPLE WHO RECOVERED FROM
COVID, AS WELL AS INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAVE BEEN VACCINATED, AND
WHO DEVELOPED DIFFERENT TYPES
OF ANTIBODIES TO BLOCK THE
VIRUS.
AND WE WILL SEE, IF IN FACT
THIS PARTICULAR VIRUS IS STILL
SENSITIVE TO THE ANTIBODIES
THAT WILL INDUCE BY THE
VACCINES THAT WE ARE USING.
WE EXPECT, AND I WOULDN'T BE
SURPRISED, IF THE LEVEL OF
PROTECTION DIMINISHES SOMEWHAT,
GIVEN THE CONSTELLATIONS OF
MUTATIONS THAT WE SEE, THAT
WOULD SUGGEST IMMUNIZATION
THERE.
BUT YOU NEVER KNOW, UNTIL YOU
TESTED.
AND IN THOSE SITUATION --
THEN YOU GET INTO THE REAL
WORLD DATA, ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN A VACCINATED PERSON OR
BOOSTED PERSON COMES INTO
CONTACT AND GETS INFECTED.
THESE ARE ALL THINGS THAT ARE
UNKNOWN.
WE'LL GET THE LABORATORY DATA
AND A COUPLE OF WEEKS, BUT WILL
HAVE TO GET EXPERIENCE FROM OUR
SOUTH AFRICAN COLLEAGUES, ABOUT
WHAT THE REAL CLINICAL EFFECT
IS GONNA BE.
>> DOCTOR FAUCI, GOOD EVENING.
YOU JUST HEARD KAITLAN COLLINS
TALKING ABOUT THE FACT THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS GONNA BE LAYING
OUT A STRATEGY, AND HOW TO
FIGHT COVID THIS WINTER.
NOW, AS CHIEF MEDICAL ADVISER,
I'M CURIOUS WHAT ARE YOU
TELLING HIM THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING TO STRESS THIS TO THE
COUNTRY?
AND WHAT, IF ANY, POLICY
CHANGES SHOULD YOU THINK SHOULD
BE IMPLEMENTED?
CAITLIN, MENTIONED THE
POSSIBILITY OF MASK MANDATES
NOW ON PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION,
SOMETHING HAS BEEN CONSIDERED.
>> SANJAY, AS YOU KNOW, I'M NOT
GONNA GET AHEAD OF THE
PRESIDENT IN THE SPEECH THAT
HE'S GONNA GIVE AT OUR PLACE AT
THE NIH TOMORROW.
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT,
BUT YOU KNOW, AND THE VERY VERY
CONSTANT INTERACTIONS THAT I
AND THE MEDICAL TEAM HAVE HAD
WITH HIM OVER THE LAST FEW DAYS,
WE'RE EMPHASIZING, AND HE'S
ACCEPTING VERY READILY, THE
KINDS OF THINGS THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
MAKING SURE THAT THE
UNVACCINATED GET VACCINATED.
AND THAT PEOPLE ARE FULLY
VACCINATED, GET THEIR BOOSTERS
AS QUICKLY AS THEY POSSIBLY CAN,
IF THEY ARE ELIGIBLE.
BECAUSE THE QUESTION ARISES,
YOU JUMP AHEAD OF YOURSELF, AND
YOU SAY, WELL, IS THERE GOING
TO BE A VARIANT SPECIFIC BOOST?
AND IF SO, SHOULD I WAIT TO GET
THAT BOOST?
AND THE ANSWER IS NO.
IF YOU ARE ELIGIBLE, NAMELY IF
YOU'VE HAD THE MODERNA OR THE
PFIZER, AND YOUR 6 MONTHS
FOLLOWING YOUR PRIMARY REGIMENT
OF VACCINATION, AND YOU ARE 2
MONTHS FOLLOWING J&J, DON'T
WAIT.
GET THAT EXTRA BOOST NOW,
BECAUSE WE KNOW WHEN YOU DO
THAT, THE LEVEL OF ANTIBODIES,
AS I THINK YOU MENTIONED ON
THIS SHOW, SANJAY, THE LEVEL OF
ANTIBODIES THAT RISE AND GO UP,
FOLLOWING A BOOST, IS MUCH,
MUCH HIGHER THAN THE PEAK LEVEL
THAT YOU GET AFTER YOUR 2ND
DOSE OF A 2 DOSE VACCINE.
THAT'S WHAT YOU REALLY WANT TO
SEE, BECAUSE WE KNOW, FROM OUR
EXPERIENCE WITH DELTA, THAT
EVEN THOUGH THE VACCINE IS NOT
DIRECT DID SPECIFICALLY A DELTA,
IT IS DIRECTED AGAINST THE AND
STRESSFUL STRAIN, THE WUHAN
STRAIN.
YET, WHEN YOU GET YOUR LEVELS
OF ANTI-BODY HIGH ENOUGH, YOU
PROTECT AGAINST DELTA.
THAT'S WHERE WE'RE HOPING WILL
SEE WHERE THE OMICRON VARIANT
--
THAT IF YOU GET YOUR LEVELS
HIGH ENOUGH, IT WILL SPILL OVER
AND GET CROSS PROTECTION
AGAINST THAT VARIANT.
>> IT'S KEEP TALKING ABOUT
IMMUNITY AND ANTIBODIES.
YOU MAY REMEMBER, BACK IN
SEPTEMBER, WE ASKED YOU ABOUT
WHETHER WE SHOULD TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THE IMPACT OF NATURAL
OR INFECTION ACQUIRED IMMUNITY,
WHEN IT COMES TO VACCINATION
STATUS.
THIS CONTINUES TO BE AN
IMPORTANT TOPIC FOR MANY
PEOPLE.
I JUST WANT TO REMIND YOU, TAKE
A LISTEN TO WHAT YOU SAID BACK
THEN ON AC360.
>> IT'S CONCEIVABLE THAT YOU
GOT INFECTED OR PROTECTED, BUT
YOU MAY NOT BE PROTECTED FOR
THE DEATH THAT APPEARED ON
TIME.
SO I THINK THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE SIT DOWN AND DISCUSS
SERIOUSLY.
>> SO THAT WAS A COUPLE OF
MONTHS AGO, NOW.
WHERE DO WE STAND ON THE IDEA
OF THE PROTECTION THAT YOU GET
FROM HAVING HAD COVID?
>> WELL, THERE IS NO DOUBT,
SANJAY, THAT IF YOU ARE
INFECTED WITH SARS-COV-2, AND
YOU RECOVER, THAT YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE A SIGNIFICANT DEGREE OF
PROTECTION.
WHICH WE DON'T KNOW, BECAUSE IT
HASN'T BEEN STUDIED AS
PRECISELY AS THE
POSTVACCINATION IMMUNOLOGICAL
RESPONSE.
THAT WE DON'T KNOW WITH THE
DURABILITY OF THIS IS, AND WHAT
THE LEVEL IS.
AND PEOPLE WHO PUSH BACK AND
SAY, WAIT A MINUTE, ARE YOU
SAYING THAT YOU DON'T GET
PROTECTION.
NO, YOU GET A CONSIDERABLE
DEGREE OF PROTECTION FROM
GETTING INFECTED AND RECOVER.
BUT THE THING THAT WE DO KNOW
THAT WE ARE VERY SURE OF, THAT
IF YOU TAKE AN INFECTED PERSON,
WHO HAS RECOVERED, AND THEN YOU
VACCINATE THAT PERSON, THAT'S
THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF PROTECTION,
BOTH T CELLS ANTIBODY, AND ALL
PARAMETERS, IT GETS WAY, WAY
HIGHER THAN ANYTHING ELSE.
AND THAT'S THE REASON WHY THE
CDC CONTINUES TO RECOMMEND THAT
IF YOU HAVE BEEN INFECTED, THAT
YOU SUBSEQUENTLY GET VACCINATED
FOR THE OPTIMAL PERMIT
PROTECTION.
THERE IS OBVIOUSLY, CONCERNED
ABOUT OMICRON IN THE PAST FEW
DAYS, BUT THE DELTA VARIANT IS
STILL VERY SERIOUS CONCERN HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES.
MICHIGAN REPORTED THAT THERE
WAS NOT A HOSPITAL SITE UNDER
PERCENT PATIENT CAPACITY, HOW
CONCERNED ARE YOU ABOUT WHAT IS
TO COME?
>> I'M GLAD YOU BROUGHT THAT UP,
ANDERSON, BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT
PEOPLE, BECAUSE THEY HEAR OF A
SINGLE CASE OF A NEW VARIANT,
THAT JUST HAS NOW ARRIVED IN
THE UNITED STATES, AS WELL AS
WHAT IS GOING ON IN SOUTH
AFRICA, OR IN OTHER COUNTRIES
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD, TO TAKE
OUR EYE OFF THE BALL OF THE
PROBLEM THAT WE ARE FACING
RIGHT NOW.
WE ARE ENTERING INTO A MUCH
COLDER SEASON, WE STILL HAVE
99.9% OF THE ISOLATES ARE DELTA,
AND WE KNOW WHAT WE CAN DO WITH
DELTA.
WE HAVE, WITHIN OUR CAPABILITY,
TO BLOCK IT.
BY GETTING THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
UNVACCINATED VACCINATED, AND WE
STILL HAVE ABOUT 60 MILLION
PEOPLE WHO ARE ELIGIBLE TO BE
VACCINATED WHO ARE NOT
VACCINATED.
AND TO GET THOSE PEOPLE, WHO
ARE ALREADY PRIMARILY
VACCINATED, FULLY VACCINATED,
TO GET THEM WHEN THEY ARE A
LITTLE TROUBLE TO GET THE
BOOSTER, FOR THE REASONS I JUST
SAID.
THEN WE HAVE OTHER THINGS, AND
YOU MENTIONED THEM JUST A BIT
AGO, WEARING PROPER MASKS WHEN
YOU ARE IN AN INDOOR CONGREGATE
SETTING, GETTING THE CHILDREN
VACCINATED, THAT'S REALLY VERY
IMPORTANT.
WE HAVE 28 MILLION CHILDREN
BETWEEN THE AGES OF 5 AND 11,
HAVE WE GET THEM BUT SEDATED
WILL PROTECT THEM FOR THEIR OWN
HEALTH, AS WELL AS TO PREVENT
THE FURTHER SPREAD IN THE
COMMUNITY.
SO THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS WE
CAN DO NOW WITH WHAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH NOW, AND WHAT
WE'RE DEALING WITH NOW IS
DELTA.
>> DOCTOR FAUCI, I DO WANT TO
GET ONE AUDIENCE QUESTION IN
BEFORE WE GO TO THE BREAK,
WE'RE GONNA HAVE PLENTY MORE
AFTER.
SEAN FROM VIRGINIA HAS A
QUESTION ABOUT TRAVELING FOR
THE HOLIDAYS.
LET'S WATCH.
>> MY FAMILY IS PLANNING ON
TRAVELING TO EUROPE THIS
CHRISTMAS, WE'RE ALL VACCINATED
INCLUDING OUR BOOSTERS, EXCEPT
FOR MY SON WHO IS 13, HE'S NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR HIS BOOSTER, I'M
WONDERING IF IT'S SAFE TO
TRAVEL, I'M ALSO NERVOUS ABOUT
LAST-MINUTE TRAVEL RESTRICTIONS,
SHOULD I BE?
>> I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
CURIOUS ABOUT THIS DOCTOR FAUCI,
I KNOW YOU ARE PLANNING TO GET
TOGETHER WITH YOUR FAMILY THIS
HOLIDAY SEASON, FULLY
VACCINATED WITHOUT MASKS.
DOES OMICRON CHANGE YOUR
THINKING ON THIS, WHAT SHOULD
OTHER PEOPLE BE THINKING?
>> NO.
THANKS FOR THE QUESTION SANJAY,
BECAUSE I'M GETTING IT ASKED A
LOT MYSELF.
I WOULD NOT DO ANYTHING
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT WE HAVE
BEEN RECOMMENDED ALL ALONG,
DESPITE THE FACT WE HAVE A CASE.
AND WE ARE LIKELY TO SEE MORE
CASES OF OMICRON AS THE WEEKS
IN THE DAYS GO BY, I WOULD BE
SURPRISED, ALREADY SAID IT A
LITTLE BIT AGO, I WOULDN'T BE
SURPRISED IF WE SAY THE FIRST
CASE SOON.
WE JUST HAVE A PROBLEM LET'S
IDENTIFY WILL NOW, AND JUST AS
I SAY, AND I'LL SAY IT AGAIN.
IF YOU ARE VACCINATED SITUATION,
YOUR FAMILY IS VACCINATED,
ENJOY THE HOLIDAYS, INDOOR WITH
YOUR FAMILY IN A FAMILY
SETTING.
MANY OF US WILL HAVE TO TRAVEL
DURING THE HOLIDAYS.
WHAT YOU DO WHEN YOU TRAVEL,
YOU TAKE CARE, YOU OPERATIVES.
TRAVEL ALWAYS INCREASES
SOMEWHAT, THE RISK OF GETTING
INFECTED.
BUT IF YOU WEAR A MASK,
PARTICULARLY WHEN YOU'RE IN AN
AIRPORT, IN THE CONGREGATE
SENDING.
YOU HAVE TO WEAR A MASK WHEN
YOU GET ON THE PLANE.
AND IF YOU CAN, JUST GET
VACCINATED AS SOON AS YOU CAN,
AND RIGHT NOW IS THE TIME TO
GET BOOSTED.
THE CHILDREN, ALSO, NOW IS THE
TIME T